Sean Williams got a sober yeah like we
Knoxville and I were not sober when we
made Dukes of Hazard Johnny Knoxville
and Sean William Scott had both been in
movies action movies with The Rock and
The Rock had it has a joke right as they
roll the camera's rolling sound he'll
like bump Knoxville he goes did you get
into that cocaine last night now
Sean and Johnny are in the car in the
Dukes of car together a million times
and he leans ever goes did you get into
that cocaine last night and knock knock
laughing laughing laughing yeah I get a
call the president of Warren brothers
wants to talk to Sean William Scott and
Sean's like dude do you hear the
president wants to talk to me and I'm
like yeah he goes am I getting Superman
and I'm like
maybe holy right like we don't know
we all think he's getting Superman so
basically he heard the president heard
this thing about the cocaine and he and
he asked him and he goes no no and he's
like I'm the only one not doing cocaine